[Musica]
grazie grazie sono alessio berni
ringrazio sentitamente per questo invito
che per noi è un momento importantissimo
per raccontare un po quella che è la
nostra storia fatta di passione
ovviamente fatta di cuore fatta di
impresa io nel contesto è la mia vita ho
sempre virus vissuto in un contesto di
imprenditori ne ho fatte faceva
l'imprenditore ai miei amici fanno gli
imprenditori e la passione ci ha
accomunato a condividere un percorso un
percorso insieme
lo facciamo sul nostro territorio perché
la terra che amo la terra che mi ha dato
tutto quindi vorrei continuare a vivere
fino alla morte e lo sottolineo fino
alla morte nel mio territorio e a
lavorare il mio territorio ea dare
opportunità agli altri di vivere in
questo territorio che è un posto
meraviglioso splendido che offre
tantissime opportunità è proprio legato
al territorio ringrazio sentitamente
questa organizzazione che per la prima
volta a siena ha dato vita a questo the
dix che è un momento veramente
importante che mette risalto le
peculiarità legate alla nostra imprese e
alle nostre idee ai nostri progetti
quindi come vi dicevo io sono un
innamorato dell'italia innamorato del
nostro territorio ed è per questo che
sono innamorato dei nostri prodotti che
nel mondo hanno veramente un valore
aggiunto incredibile solamente uscendo
dai confini della nostra italia
riusciamo a capire quanto quanto di
importante
e quanto valore abbiamo ancora nel resto
del mondo siamo visti veramente come
eccellenze internazionali qualche volta
quando ci guardiamo intorno a casa
spesso perdiamo di vista questo
aspettano ma credetemi ci sono reduce da
un recente viaggio con la mia famiglia
negli stati uniti dove siamo stati quasi
un mese e vedere con che occhi ancora e
con questi ma ci guardano ci dovrebbe
far tornare tutti nel nostro paese
orgogliosi di quello che facciamo e di
quello e di come lo facciamo
abbiamo lasciato testimonianze
importantissime che ancora oggi segnano
delle icone
a livello internazionali quindi dobbiamo
essere veramente fieri di quello che
abbiamo fatto e di quello che
continueremo a fare
paradossalmente abbiamo creato molto
abbiamo creato molto ma l'italiano ha la
caratteristica di creare oggetti e
progetti che in qualche modo rispondano
ad esigenze umane esigenze legate al
lavoro esigenze legate al contesto di
vita vissuta del contesto relativo
piuttosto che del vivere quotidiano
esigenze legate al benessere fisico
piuttosto che al muoversi al muoversi al
viaggiare a conoscere esplorare nuovi
confini e nuove e nuove nuovi orizzonti
la creatività e la genialità italiana
lo dico con fierezza e veramente un
valore aggiunto di cui noi dobbiamo
essere orgogliosi e dobbiamo portare
avanti questo messaggio
negli anni e nei secoli ci siamo
contraddistinti per aver fatto molte
invenzioni tante invenzioni
forse io nel mio piccolo mi sento in
qualche modo portatore di questo
messaggio di questo percorso
al punto che ci siamo ci siamo messi
alla ricerca di nuovi materiali che
potessero in qualche modo soddisfare le
esigenze produttive che avevamo da
sempre come ha sottolineato melani la
mia produzione io sono innamorato di
design di progetti di oggetti e insieme
a uno dei miei soci che anzi porta i
suoi saluti visto che non è potuto
essere presente che alessandro campinoti
forse molti di voi nel territorio lo
conoscano perché uno dei fondatori della
del gruppo pramac di ben altre
dimensioni rispetto alla nostra impresa
siamo da sempre innamorati di quello che
è il design italiano di quelli che sono
gli oggetti che contraddistinguono un po
l'italian style nel mondo e quindi come
i sognatori con il cuore e con la
passione ci siamo messi a creare una
serie di oggetti voleva fare degli
oggetti particolari che non fossero
oggetti comuni
che in qualche modo si starebbero
trovato in concorrenza con cose che
ormai sono abbastanza inflazionato e
purtroppo in italia
soffriamo molto di prodotti
concorrenziali soprattutto nel contesto
e arredamento prodotti che arrivano dall
importazione e che penalizzano spesso il
design italiano in quanto come dire
riescono a produrre oggetti
faccio riferimento a mercati orientali
che emulano i prodotti italiani a costi
estremamente contenuti
perché non hanno tutta una serie di
ricerche che noi facciamo è quindi sono
ben più agevolati rispetto a noi insomma
quindi noi ci siamo messi alla ricerca
di un materiale o materiale che fosse
rispondente a la nostra necessità che
prevedeva la possibilità di realizzare
prodotti che potessero stare all'esterno
quindi prodotti impegnabili meglio
ancora se galleggianti prodotti che non
avessero vincoli particolari di stampi
per la produzione perché spesso quando
iniziamo a nuovi percorsi produttivi
costruire uno stampo per un prodotto e
subito un gap forte da un punto di vista
di investimento prodotti che
rispondessero a un rispetto ambientale
importante e prodotti che avessero
caratteristiche di poter essere
utilizzati in locali pubblici quindi in
infrazione e quant'altro prodotti che
rispondessero appunto a delle esigenze e
delle esigenze e da qui ci siamo messi
alla ricerca di nuovi materiali e
abbiamo capito che usando il conosciuto
polistirolo le famose palline di
polistirolo che tutti vedete negli
imballi che trovate un materiale
estremamente povero misero devo dire no
ecco noi partendo da questo materiale
che rispondeva a tutte le nostre
caratteristiche che erano appunto la
leggerezza
parliamo di solo 20 kg a metro cubo o 30
kg massima metro cubo alla possibilità
di lavorarlo senza vincoli di stampi
alla unificazione perché materiale
ignifugo ma soprattutto anche alla
possibilità di poterlo riutilizzare una
volta che era stato usato come prodotto
finito
e quindi ha un impatto ambientale
pressoché zero quindi questo prodotto ci
garantiva tutta una serie di
caratteristiche rispondenti alle nostre
esigenze
ovviamente così come lo conosciamo noi è
come dire non avrebbe dato risultato in
nessun genere
quindi ci siamo attivati affinché
potessero costruire dei blocchi di
materiale dei blocchi enormi di
materiale e lavorarlo poi di conseguenza
come vediamo qua nel questa in questa
vignetta
noi partiamo da dei blocchi da dei
blocchi di materiale sono dei biscottoni
che facciamo comporre e sono blocchi da
4 metri per un metro per un metro quindi
sono dei parallelepipedi enormi che
tagliamo attraverso delle macchine a
controllo numerico
dopodiché l'innovazione che abbiamo
apportato al povero polistirolo lo
chiamo io povero ma in realtà è
diventato un materiale molto ricco lo
resin chiamo con una resina particolare
e come abbiamo scritto ma sotto abbiamo
fatto crea abbiamo fatto nascere il poli
mas che è un materiale ideato appunto
dalla nostra società che nasce
dall'unione delle ps quale polistirolo
espanso ad alta densità rivestite
strutturato con particolare termini
resine termoindurenti in poche parole
noi andiamo a prendere questi blocchi li
pago miamo l'italiano come riteniamo
opportuno devo dire che quindi abbiamo
la testimonianza diretta
la scritta the forse et et des dix siena
è una realizzazione con il nostro
materiale una volta ha lavorato il
materiale è come se gli portiamo addosso
una una sostanza che lo rende
strutturale sembra un'operazione banale
ma questo ad oggi paradossalmente non
era mai stato fatto in italia
quindi il vantaggio è che abbiamo un
materiale galleggiante un materiale
leggero materiale impermeabile un
materiale autoestinguente economico eco
sostenibile fonoassorbente termoisolante
riciclabile portante
e strutturale questo devo dire ci ha
fatto ci ha fatto come dire ci ha
riempito il cuore di gioia aver creato
una cosa del genere ma soprattutto ci ha
spalancato gli occhi per mettere in moto
una realtà imprenditoriale che a
distanza di un anno ci sta regalando
veramente grande soddisfazione sia da un
punto di vista di accreditamento perché
le nostre forniture poi è stata facendo
promuove farebbero vedere sono arrivate
in platee importanti ma soprattutto
anche da un punto di vista di risultati
un'impresa
oggi la nostra società a distanza di
dieci anni come dire include già una
decina di persone e quindi è una
opportunità di lavoro e sta regalando
anche a noi nonostante grossi
investimenti che stiamo facendo dei
risultati significativi il nostro
materiale pertanto è ideale per lavorare
nel contesto degli allestimenti quindi
riusciamo a fare insegne pubblicitarie
come ho detto quando abbiamo
testimonianza elementi per vetrinistica
cartelli loghi stand fieristici nel
mondo dell'oggettistica che è quello
dove noi volevamo lavorare cioè vale a
dire nel mondo del design nell'edilizia
piuttosto che nell'industria
abbiamo due possibilità di utilizzo le
realizzazioni personalizzate quindi le
customizzazione e le realizzazioni
seriali che la collezione stay light qua
di seguito e tutto quello che riusciamo
a realizzare
sottolineo che prodotti sono
galleggianti
concludo però un aspetto importante e
credo sia l'occasione giusta allora noi
crediamo fermamente che il mondo
dell'università possa rappresentare una
grande opportunità per le imprese
soprattutto imprese del territorio
università del territorio
abbiamo trovato grande sensibilità al
dipartimento industriale dell'università
di architettura di napoli
vorremmo che la stessa cosa forse quella
stessa sensibilità forse anche
espressione del territorio e ci
auguriamo che un domani a stretto giro
possiamo collaborare anche con le locali
università
del territorio anche perché connubio
imprese e territorio e studenti credo
sia la chiave di volta per il futuro
delle imprese italiane ci credo
fermamente nel sono fermamente convinto
e ringrazio sentitamente tutti per la
disponibilità per l'attenzione buon
futuro a tutti grazie di cuore
ciao
[Applauso]
[Musica]